[Music]
so one of my favorite phenomena that's
happening across the world
is
men are taking credit for women's work
[Laughter]
so the spanish literary world has been
thrown into chaos after a book prize was
awarded to uh a woman named carmen mola
who is an acclaimed female thriller
writer
who turned out to to uh
be a man
to be three guys
like ghost writing yeah
not ghost writing what yeah the pen name
yeah like shakespeare the concept are
you sure like satoshi nakamoto
shakespeare's not a person well there's
a theory there's a theory that
shakespeare is also the biggest but
there's a there's a picture with them
with a crusty the clown thing man
damn yeah conspiracy i don't know if
it's true but you know what i'm saying
wow that's very interesting to choose to
do that like they choose to be a lady
old
men choosing to
pose as a baby they won this award right
and they they took to the stage to pick
up the prize money and reveal that they
were her and that she doesn't exist so
how did they get invited if
under the the pseudonym it worked yeah
so they they're like
so they exposed it to somebody then uh
maybe i don't know probably one of the
big reveal
you said you said uh that pseudonym is
famous for thrillers yeah oh dude um
stephen king's son
is a writer and he has success but he
used a different name because he didn't
want everyone to think stephen king so
my book needs to be as good or whatever
even stephen king actually started doing
that he even created his own
for other brands because if he wanted to
do romance he's like by stephen king
but then he uh he got found out
isn't there a potential problem with
this though why they do that all the
time all the time bro yeah well it's
it's more like the idea well okay okay
never mind
i think there was a guy i never
pretended to be asian to write some type
of script too but that's what i'm saying
like imagine if i pretend to be a woman
and i write a novel that has to do with
like womanly things but what if people
love it and it doesn't matter
that's that's kind of the best part it
usually happens for like fair enough
fiction and just like
like
make belief [ __ ] not like non-fiction
and self-help and like
biographies and things like that that
would be tight if it was for non-fiction
i mean like my
my pen name is dr cleopatra
[Laughter]
you know you're not a doctor at all
she's like a african-american or just
i'm black as a as a pseudonym and then i
write like stories from africa that
happens to like win an award yeah
because i'm representing something that
needs to be spoken about and then when i
go to accept my award i look like this
am i just kidding my name is actually
anthony lee hey someone's going to get
you though they needed a good sick job
right i just wanted to know i just
wanted to ask because if everyone loves
it and connects with it and like that's
so true that's so real and true and then
you stand up you're like i'm anthony lee
genjus
[Laughter]
that's how i see it there's that ivan
ramen guy in japan
that makes like michelin star because it
depends on the content yeah and everyone
in japan loves his [ __ ] he's just but
he's just a jewish dude from new york
but does he pose he doesn't know that
he's japanese he should that's what i'm
saying you know what i'm saying
it's different but again that's why i
asked like what's the type of content if
it's like a butterfly wasn't written by
an asian
it was been by like a french lady or
some [ __ ] maybe some of the best sushi
i've ever had my whole life comes from a
place called ralph's
stupid
where it tastes like the refrigerator
it's very good ralph's a japanese guy
yeah when it has craft philadelphia
[ __ ] cream cheese but there's usually
japanese people making it though there
is almost always japanese almost always
japanese that's true even at the
vallarta there's always a [ __ ]
there's always a bunch of japanese
people they're ham in the sushi section
too man dude
this sushi section is like underrated
bro this is it i don't know if i trust
them because their tamales were not good
so the mines are hit or miss though
because you know why because you can
just get tamales from like a family
friend you get at the parking lot yeah
yeah dude there's a lady that's like hey
you want the tamales i'm like yeah mommy
got a tamale connection
and she takes off her mask i'm like it's
anthony lee
ginger
but i feel like man those are pretty
good yeah dude home depot parking lot
tamale
here we go longest tamales have had just
home depot parking lot i think it
depends on context right because like if
people are writing like a asian rights
activist menu and then like we find out
later that it was like some mexican dude
or whatever and i'm like what or like
being a rachel dolezal or some [ __ ] like
i think that's pretty [ __ ] up because
what if he had dope ideas for asian
lives dude he's like yo these are the
sickest most lit
ideas
you know what it does steve what if
steve produces a tv show about asian
rights and casts all asians but he's the
executive producer oh that's fine
because it's not
his
so you know what it so shang chi right
that's shang chi yeah
that's that's dope is that that green
flip the whole project it was probably a
white guy it was all asian stuff isn't
it
i get boys
[ __ ] it no
i just tried i just tried i didn't
[ __ ] speak chinese i think it's it's
you got to look at each context right
and the motive because
because some people are what do you call
it like the the the fraud race peoples
like
like yeah like they pretend that they're
black but they're actually born white or
whatever well that one lady rachel
dolezal that's right
and then so like what it does is it
hurts the movement because
it's like like you're an asian activist
you're not even asian you're born white
and then when they find out that you
were a fraud then even if you did dope
[ __ ] yeah it kind of discredits
everything but it's really good for only
fans though rachel dolezal's
only fans is killing it
yeah
yeah what type of content is a great
question there's different things on
there she stays black on all me
yeah
see i don't want to see her [ __ ]
tell him i wasn't lying and she kept her
braids
let's see that [ __ ] 5.99 a month it's
hard to see it but yeah oh no but it
says duty
she has the only fans
thankfulness thursday oh where you buy
stuff off of her wishes does only
fantastic
wow
she wild dude
but yeah she says she'll do um
yeah you can take pictures of her or
she'll she'll just do whatever you want
all right so three dudes uh writing as a
as a
did they explain like why they chose
that what like what their motive was um
they just said that they wanted to write
this book and that they um it's not lost
on anybody
that somebody um
who who could exist who wrote this book
basically like what was their motive of
choosing like a female writer instead of
like a male writer's name or like
that's what i'm saying that's why i'm
like that's interesting i feel like
that's like a marketing thing think
about it it's female
spanish
are they what's their
origin like well they're just
it's funny because they say in an
interview with the real authors
following the revelation um they
reported it's not lost on anyone that
the idea of a university professor and
mother of three who teaches algebra
classes in the morning and in the
afternoon writes novels of savage and
macabre violence it has a good marketing
operation
oh so the contrast of a woman
who's writing these crazy thriller
novels is like well that's interesting
yeah oh okay it's a total angle yeah
yeah so again i pose the same question
is there not a potential problem in this
somewhere i mean i see a problem because
then
why couldn't they have just helped a
lady who is a single mom and going
through the same process why couldn't
they have helped her out because a real
single mom can't write a book yeah
that's probably wrong they accurately in
the book they actually described
that no in the book they actually
because the book is about a woman who's
a detective who's going through this and
also she has her period a lot
are you [ __ ] not every child
uh
every chapter is a different month
i think i read this book and then as she
was chasing the suspect yeah she was
chasing the suspect the suspect was a
female 2 and their period synced up oh
my gosh so they both had to chill out
yeah they kept buying like tampons so
they knew each other's weaknesses yeah
stoop so that she followed the different
cvs's that she went to to [ __ ] buy
tampons they would just bump into each
other at self-checkout all the time
i was like this should win on board
guess what it did so we were right
and the haters were wrong and everybody
who judged and gave the award they're
all women but then once they gave the
award they're like actually we're all
men
and they said no we're kidding we
actually are just old dudes
that's a love there he is yeah yeah
you're right there's no problem here
it's a great feel-good story
reading it then i felt good reading it
now
should we all read the book is there
controversy though like yeah yeah of
course so are they like yeah
is it is it like is it like you the
basic argument but uh yeah
it's like you you shouldn't pretend to
be a woman when you're not yeah well
beyond using a female pseudonym these
guys spent years doing interviews it's
not just the name it's the fake profile
they use to like take these people and
build a fan base with it it's just that
they like and the sob story yeah yeah
yeah yeah just sell books you know did
they use a photo of an actual woman to
represent the name
uh it doesn't say that they did no i
don't see it because how could you
become popular famous and not get
googled to see what you look like or
have a profile huh show me a picture of
banksy
hey show me a picture of a kenja dude
without the [ __ ] mask
steve
just
just once just an adult conversation
this guy
[Music]
you